>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> William Jacobs:
Good afternoon.
My name is William
Jacobs and I'm the Chief
of the Interpretive
Programs Office.
The Interpretive Programs
Office or IPO is responsible
for the development
of new exhibitions
and related educational programs
at the Library of Congress.
Today's event, co-sponsored
by IPO and the Law Library
of Congress, is presented in
conjunction with the Library
of Congress exhibition, "The
Civil Rights Act of 1964:
A Long Struggle for Freedom".
This important exhibition
commemorates the 50th
anniversary of the landmark
Civil Rights Act of 1964
that looks at events that
shaped the Civil Rights Movement
and explores the
far-reaching impact of the act
on a changing society.
Located in the historic
Thomas Jefferson building
across the street, the
exhibition has attracted more
than 355,000 visitors
since it opened
to the public last
fall on September 10th.
In addition, educational
programming related
to the exhibition held
to date it includes more
than 135 exhibition tours
for groups of all types,
nine gallery talks by library
specialists featuring items
on display in the exhibition,
a February 2015 public
film series featuring four
full-length television
documentaries
from the Civil Rights
era in celebration
of Black History Month, a
public book talk and signing
by author Clay Risen on his
book, "The Bill of the Century:
The Epic Battle for
the Civil Rights Act",
two onsite workshops,
and three online webinars
for K-12 teachers focused on
teaching about Civil Rights
with original and
digitized primary sources
from the exhibition.
The exhibition, funded
by a generous grant
from Newman's Own Foundation
and with additional support
from History, has been extended
through January 2nd, 2016.
Please check the library's
website for visiting hours
and continuously
updated information
about upcoming educational
programs related
to the exhibition.
At this time, I'd
like to welcome
and introduce our speaker,
Patricia A. Sullivan.
Patricia Sullivan is a Professor
of History at the University
of South Carolina and Director
of a series of summer institutes
at Harvard University's
WEB Du Bois Institute
on Teaching the History of
the Civil Rights Movement.
Her publications include,
"Lift Every Voice", "The NAACP
and the Making of the
Civil Rights Movement",
published in 2009, "Freedom
Writer: Virginia Foster Durr,
Letters from the Civil Rights
Years", printed in 2003,
and "Days of Hope:
Race and Democracy
in the Deal Era",
published in 1996.
She is coeditor of the
"John Hope Franklin Series
in African American History
and Culture" at the University
of North Carolina Press.
Prof. Sullivan also
served as one
of the scholarly advisers
during the conceptual planning
of the Civil Rights
Act exhibition.
She will now share her
thoughts on her current project,
a book on Robert F. Kennedy,
"Civil Rights and the Struggle
for Racial Justice
in the 1960s".
Patricia? [Applause]
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
Thank you very much
for that introduction
and to all of the folks
in the Interpretive
Programs Office
who created this remarkable
exhibit that working on it was
such a pleasure and
I learned so much.
And it's wonderful that it
will be here through December.
So I hope if you haven't seen
it that you will go and see it.
It's really, really terrific.
Thank you all for coming and
I thank my friends for coming.
Today, it's-- the Civil Rights
Act stands as a living monument
to the Civil Rights
Movement and that's
so beautifully demonstrated
in this exhibit.
The exhibit captures a broad
sweep in dynamic history
that culminated with the
Civil Rights Act in 1964,
legislation that changed
America in fundamental ways,
ending the racial class
system in the South
and expanding federal
protection of citizenship rights
that continues to
shape our lives
and create new opportunities.
The exhibit also
documents a history
that is closely intertwined
with America's long
struggle with race.
It includes a large flag,
proclaiming a man was lynched
today, that would hang outside
of the NAACP's office
on 5th Avenue,
documenting whenever a lynching
happened during the 1920s
and 1930s.
And it's-- really to see it,
I was with Julia Mum
[assumed spelling],
we saw it in the exhibit and
we both just froze to see it,
it's gigantic, hung way up.
And it's a summary reminder of
the depths of racial brutality
and national indifference
that has marked our history.
Recent incidents
of police violence
and killings shine a light
on the persistent legacies
and manifestations of America's
ongoing racial dilemma.
So, I welcome this opportunity
to talk with you today
about Robert Kennedy and
his history in relationship
to the Civil Right Act and the
movement that it grew from.
Circumstances placed Robert
Kennedy in a unique position
to respond to the challenges
and opportunities created
by the Civil Rights Movement
at its most pivotal moment.
First, some backgrounds
since I've been digging
in the archives to
get a chance to talk
about your project is dangerous,
you know, because you're--
yeah, but I think
it's interesting
to know what I've been
struck by, the combination
of individual characteristics
and experiences
that help explain more
about Kennedy's development
as a rare leader in
America's long struggle
for racial justice.
He had the self-assuredness
and sense of entitlement common
to a son of privilege.
He was fiercely ambitious,
though not for personal
recognition or advancement,
and had a finely tuned
sense of right and wrong.
Labeled a misfit by his
high school classmates,
he did not hesitate to
go against the grain
of established practices.
He was compassionate and
demonstrated an ability
to attract and cultivate people
who shared his dedication
to public service like Peter
Edelman who joins us today.
Most significantly, I
think is what colleagues
and friends called his
experiencing nature.
As one associate
recalled, he went,
he saw, he listened, he grew.
Born in 1925, Robert
Kennedy came of age at a time
when segregation was becoming
more deeply entrenched
throughout the country, even
as the NAACP mounted
the protracted challenge
of segregation in the
South that culminated
with the 1954 Brown Ruling.
The 1950s, the decade
that Kennedy began
his professional life,
marked the largest migration of
African-Americans from the South
to the North and
West, the culmination
of the great migration,
which dramatically altered
the racial landscape
of this country.
By 1960, an estimated 48%
of black Americans lived
in the North, trapped
in overcrowded housing,
substandard schools,
minimal access to jobs,
and aggressive policing.
Prior to 1960, the year he's
run around for president,
Kennedy said he never
thought much about race.
He grew up learning that there
are people less fortunate
who had a difficult time,
both black and white,
and that you had a
social responsibility
for doing something about it,
yet an early confrontation
with the color line
is revealing.
In 1951, during his third year
in Law School at the University
of Virginia, Kennedy
invited Ralph Bunche to speak
at the university as a guest
to the Student Legal Forum.
Bunche had just been awarded the
Nobel Peace Prize for his role
in the settlement of the
first Arab-Israeli war
and Kennedy had traveled to the
war-torn area in 1948 on the eve
of Israel's establishment.
So that's I think what
attracted him to Bunche.
Bunche accepted with
one condition,
he would not address
a segregated audience.
Segregation of public
gatherings was a law
in Virginia at that time.
There was tremendous
opposition on campus
to such an arrangement, Kennedy
later recalled, and students
on the Legal Forum were
divided about what to do.
Determined that Bunche
would visit and believed
that the policy was wrong,
Kennedy wrote a letter appealing
directly to the president
of the university,
Colgate Darden,
and I'm quoting for
that-- from that.
"The segregation policy in
this instance," he wrote,
"is legally indefensible
and morally wrong."
He cited the recent
Supreme Court decision,
McLaurin versus Oklahoma,
a 1950 ruling
which barred racial
segregation of students
within the university.
Kennedy advised,
"While the University
of Virginia offers a public
lecture open to citizens
of the state, it cannot
require college citizens
in attending these addresses to
be seated in segregated areas."
In his letter, Kennedy
explain that the audience
for the forum events ran
from 300 to 400 people
and that it wasn't
likely that more than 30
or 40 blacks would attend.
Darden agreed to a temporary
suspension of the policy.
On Easter Monday,
Kennedy introduced Bunche
to an overflow crowd of more
1,500 people in Cabell Hall
on the grounds of
the university.
An estimated 500
of them were black.
This was the first public
integrated meeting of its kind
on the grounds of the
University of Virginia.
Also, there was no hotel
accommodation for Ralph Bunche
in Charlottesville so
he stayed with Bobby
and his new wife Ethel,
and it was the beginning
of a long friendship.
It was not until 1960 that
the issue of race moved
to the center of
Kennedy's attention,
the year that Kennedy
directed his brother's campaign
for the presidency.
That year, as you know, the
sit-ins ignited student protests
and expanding activism
across the South,
protests that would soon
turn national attention
to conditions in the region.
However, for presidential
candidates John F. Kennedy
and Richard Nixon, the black
vote in electoral route
to northern and western
states vastly increased
by the migration of the
'50s was of primary concern
and offering the movement
some critical leverage.
As he navigated the fault lines
dividing southern Democrats
and northern black voters,
34-year-old Robert Kennedy
was exposed to social
and political realities
that had beyond--
had been beyond his
vision and concern.
I just want to take a brief look
at several episodes
during the 1960 campaign
that reveal a sensibility
beyond political calculation,
which was important.
I forgot to show
you the picture.
I'm not paying attention to
my notes, but there he is
with Ralph Bunche
at the university.
And I like this picture
of the campaign
and he was a hard worker,
so this is probably
out of character, but
anyway, there he is.
So, the Kennedy campaign created
the first Civil Rights division
affiliated with a major party
with an integrated staff
that included Marjorie Lawson,
an attorney and a columnist
for the Pittsburg
Courier and wife
for the Civil Rights attorney
Belford Lawson, Harris Wofford,
a young constitutional
law professor
who had a personal acquaintance
with Martin Luther King
and was the first white person
to attend Harvard Law School,
and Lewis Martin, who had been
a leading labor organizer,
NAACP activist and newspaper
publisher in Detroit.
During the 1960 Democratic
Convention,
Robert Kennedy approved
the Civil Rights Plank
that went far beyond
anything offered previously.
It reads, it's three pages
long and reads like a blueprint
for the Civil Rights
Act of 1964.
Harris Wofford and Chester
Bowles had drafted the
far-reaching in document
assuming it would be rejected
by Kennedy.
A more modest version
was ready to go.
They were surprise and delighted
when Kennedy endorsed the plank,
leading strong and determined
to charge that it was
"the most extreme,
unconstitutional,
and anti-southern
platform ever conceive
by a major political party."
Even the NAACP has never
proposed more drastic steps.
So there are several
interesting examples
that show Robert Kennedy
pressing at the edges
and his brother working to
placate southern Democrats.
I want to mention
one in particular
and then one-- a
more familiar one.
But one that I really think
is fascinating is an account
by George Peek who has worked on
the southern campaign for JFK,
he was an aide to George
Smather, and recalls a trip
with Robert Kennedy
through Georgia to Savannah.
This is Peek.
The advanced man had
a route to the hotel.
Bobby said, "Is it through
the black part of town?"
We said, "No."
He said, "Well, I want to go
through the black part of town."
So we did, we changed
the trip into Savannah.
Then when we got there, the
first thing he asks me was,
find out how many blacks we're
going to have here tonight.
Well, I knew we weren't
going to have any
because that hotel will not
have blacks in those days.
I went back to him
and said we weren't.
He said, well, we're not going
to have dinner unless you
get some blacks here, OK?
So he went about inviting
some blacks that evening.
He was very difficult to
work with, very difficult.
[Laughter] Shortly
after that incident,
and this is more well-known,
this is really the
only thing people talk
about in relationship
to the 1960 campaign
as very significant, Martin
Luther King was arrested
and jailed following
a sit-in demonstration
in Atlanta just weeks
before the election.
King, yet to be the major
national figure he would become,
was sent to a prison in
rural Reed Field, Georgia,
and there was a great
concern for his safety.
At the urging of Harris Wofford,
John F. Kennedy phoned
Coretta Scott King
to express his concern.
Independently, Robert
Kennedy called the judge
who had denied King his
constitutional right to bail
and apparently chewed him out.
RFK's call secured
King's release.
On the Sunday before
the election,
and Harris Wofford does a great
story about putting these fliers
on Graham buses and
shipping them all
over so they could be
distributed to black churches
on Sunday describing what
the Kennedy's had done
for Martin Luther King,
many blacks including
Martin Luther King Sr. voted
for John F. Kennedy as a result.
And it is likely, and Jonathan
also thinks this is true,
that the black vote provided
the margin of victory
for John F. Kennedy in the
closest presidential election
in American history
up to that point.
Now this story would end there
if Robert Kennedy had not
yielded to the pressure put
on him by his father and
brother and accepted a position
in his brother's cabinet
as attorney general.
This had major consequences
for the history of this era
and the circumstances
surrounding the Civil
Rights Act.
The transformation of
the Justice Department
in relationship to the Civil
Rights Movement began on the day
that Robert Kennedy
met John Doar,
a [inaudible] Midwestern
lawyer and Republican holdover
who had joined and pledge
to the civil rights
division the previous July.
No one else would take the job.
He was the third
person they asked.
It was the end of the
Eisenhower administration.
The division had
been established
for the 1957 Civil Rights Act,
a water dam bill conceived
to remedy voting rights
abuses in the South.
But it did give the Justice
Department some jurisdiction
in voting rights cases.
Doar and a small group of
lawyers in the division worked
to develop a government
strategy capable
of effectively prosecuting
violations of voting rights.
Reliance on FBI reports
were a problem.
They didn't include any
facts, Doar complained.
Frustrated by a flimsy report
on the mass eviction of blacks
who had attempted to register
to vote in Haywood County,
Tennessee, Doar who had been
a personal injury lawyer
for 10 years decided to go
South and see for himself.
Armed with a camera, he met
with the evicted sharecroppers,
documented their stories, took
pictures, and filed a lawsuit
in federal court that September.
This would mark an important
turning point in the work
of the Civil Rights division.
On January 19th, 1960, the day
before JFK was inaugurated,
the Civil Rights division filed
a lawsuit regarding the case
of Joseph Francis
Atlas, a black farmer
in East Carroll Parish,
Louisiana.
Doar again had gone South to
investigate this case and found
that Atlas had testified--
Before the Civil Rights
Commission in New Orleans,
he was invited to testify
about the fact that no blacks
in East Carroll Parish voted.
And after he was done,
local ginners refused
to gin his cotton.
He had about 100 acres.
He and his wife had raised
and educated eight children
and they faced financial ruin.
Robert, And this is Doar's
remembering, Robert Kennedy came
to my office the second or third
day after JFK was inaugurated
to find out what was
going on in the division.
Doar told them about the
case of Joseph Francis Atlas.
"He picked a bad place
to start," Kennedy said.
"Well, that's where Atlas
grows his cotton," he said.
And he explained how when Atlas
returned from the hearings
in new Orleans, the
sheriff met him at his door,
he told the farmer not to
bring his cotton to any ginner
in East Carroll Parish.
When Atlas asked why, the
sheriff responded, Civil Rights.
For the next week or so,
Doar recalled, Kennedy worked
to persuade the ginners of
the parish to gin the cotton
and finally secured
an agreement.
Doar advised that this
would not be sufficient.
Without a court in junction,
the agreement would be ignored.
Kennedy worked out an
arrangement whereby all
of the ginners would appear
before Judge Dawkins in Monroe,
Louisiana and pledged not to
deprive Atlas of the goods
and services he needed
to run his farm.
And he sent Doar to Monroe
to appear before the judge
and witness the agreement
on the part of the ginners.
Think of it, Doar
recalled, 50 years later,
the attorney general from
the first day put his mind
and his effort and his
energy and drive just
to help one cotton farmer
in East Carroll Parish,
Louisiana gin his cotton.
That was a good omen
for this country.
Doar would play a
major role in building
and leading the Civil
Rights division,
working under the assistance
of the attorney general
for Civil Rights, the quiet
and enormously talented
Burke Marshall.
On March 6th, Kennedy
presided over a total review
of the Justice Department's
approach to Civil Rights.
There would be no immediate
legislation introduced given
congressional and
political realities.
Energy effort and brains would
be dedicated to pushing as far
as they could on the current
Civil Rights legislation using
the persuasive and legal
pair of the administration
to secure compliance with
the segregation rulings
and voter registration laws.
Immediate attention was given
to getting the government to,
in Kennedy's words,
clean up its own act
and hire black employees.
Robert Kennedy wrote to
all the major law schools,
asking the deans "to
furnish me with the names
of qualified negro
attorneys of your acquaintance
who might be interested in
coming to the department.
We're also interested
in encouraging promising
law students
to consider making
a career here.
Voting was a top priority.
Doar's get out the roadmaps and
go was a very Kennedy approach
and it appealed to Robert
Kennedy, and will be central
to the work that defined
a vastly expanded Civil
Rights division.
Kennedy approved the
hiring of more lawyers
that he quadrupled the number
of lawyers in the division.
And the division mounted what
was in effect a field operation.
Lawyers spent weeks at a
time in the Deep South,
investigating court records
and registration documents,
interviewing blacks, and
developing a relationship
with SNCC and local
Civil Rights activists.
And this was Kennedy's idea,
they put a map up in the office
with colored pins, indicating
trouble spots and places
where cases have been filed.
Doar recalled that RFK's mantra
was, you're not doing enough.
He wanted cases in every
county in Mississippi,
Louisiana, and Alabama.
By 1963, the division
had filed 34 suits
against county registrars
for discrimination
in voter registration
and had 48 other counties
under investigation.
It had filed 12 suits seeking
injunctions against intimidation
with another eight
under investigation.
It had examined voter
registration records
in 27 counties in Alabama,
50 counties in Mississippi,
and 27 counties in Louisiana.
Still, in the short-term,
accelerated efforts
on voting rights on
the voting rights front
and escalating battles around
racial segregation pressed
at the limits of federal
power and tested the capacity
of the Kennedy administration
to meet a mounting
crisis in the south.
The state-sanctioned violence
that met the freedom writers
in the spring of 1961 was
Robert Kennedy's baptism.
He soon found out that
the FBI had failed
to disclose information that
they had on plans by the clan
with the cooperation
of local police
to assault the writers
in Alabama.
During a mass meeting at
the First Baptist Church
in Montgomery honoring
the writers,
a mob of several thousand
surrounded the church,
trapped over 1,000 people inside
and threatened to burn it down.
Robert Kennedy spent a tense
late night on the phone
with martin Luther king
who was inside the church.
While his appeals to Alabama
Governor James Paterson,
who had been a big supporter of
John F. Kennedy's, were ignored.
At the very last minute, federal
marshals dispersed the mob,
people with no experience
in mob control,
barely averting an
unspeakable human disaster.
As a result of the
freedom riots, Kennedy's--
Kennedy mandated that the ICC
enforce the Supreme Court ruling
banning segregation
on intestate commerce,
interstate travel a minor
victory in an ongoing battle.
And I just read recently
that Kennedy's never spoke
to John Paterson again.
Efforts to implement
school desegregation
in the South was a further test.
Kennedy's first speech-- public
speech was at the University
of Georgia where two black
students, Charleyne Hunter
and Hamilton Holmes that
integrated the university
that January, and he said
probably the first federal
official on southern
ground that Brown was a law
and the administration would
enforce Civil Rights laws.
He spent his first
months in office working
with Louisiana officials
successfully
to avoid a school shutdown in
the face of school desegregation
in that state, and the
Justice Department filed a suit
against Prince Edward County
which had closed their
schools rather than desegregate
and transferred the public
money to support private schools
for white children, leaving no
schools for the black children
in that community since 1959.
And Burke Marshall and John
Seigenthaler would go around
and meet with these
various communities and try
to persuade them to comply and
if not bring legal pressure.
The limits
of the administration's approach
were amplified in a number
of ways, but especially in
Mississippi in October of 1962
where the actions of a defiant
Governor Ross Barnett incited
violent resistance through the
admission of James Meredith,
leaving two people dead
and compelling the
Kennedy administration
to send federal troops
to restore order
and secure Meredith's admission.
So by early 1963, it all
seemed like patchwork at best,
as the racial conflict
in the South escalated
towards a breaking point.
Now during the same period,
Robert Kennedy's concern
about poverty and
racial segregation
that he apparently had witnessed
during the presidential
campaign deepened.
After a CBS interview in
Midtown, Manhattan earlier
in '61, he walked up to
Harlem where he talked
with young people and
observed physical conditions
of the poor segregated
urban neighborhood.
As Peter Edelman said to me
once, Bobby loved to walk,
and I love that example.
In his speech given
shortly after that
to the National Committee for
Children and Youth Conference
of Unemployed Out-of-School
Youth in Urban Areas that may,
he commented on the
interrelated problems
of school dropout rates,
youth unemployment,
and rising prison rates
for young people under 22,
and emphasized the importance
of dealing with the sources
of delinquency as opposed
to the end results.
That spring, Kennedy enlisted
his friend David Hackett
to coordinate a program
to study the cases--
the causes of juvenile
delinquency
and develop programs
to aid youth.
This resulted in
the establishment
of the President's Commission
on Juvenile Delinquency,
an interagency program housed
in the Justice Department.
Hackett drew on the
expertise of social scientists
like Richard Cloward and
Lloyd Ohlin, and the work
of Kenneth Clark in Harlem
in fashioning a program
that funded locally
initiated pilot projects.
The projects aim to mobilize the
resources of a particular city
to address the problems
of youth,
problems that they concluded
was structural and historical,
rooted in lack of access to
decent education and healthcare,
rampant unemployment, poor
recreational facilities,
racial discrimination,
and long-term poverty.
During 1961 and '62, Robert
Kennedy visited each one
of these pilot projects and
there were an estimated 16,
I'm still trying to
identify what they all were.
Hackett recalled that neither
he nor Kennedy had ever been
involved up close with poverty
or with Negros prior to this,
and they were shocked,
as they began
to see what the conditions
were like around the country.
Urban poverty became the
focus of Hackett's group
and the concept of
community action
and empowering the
poor became central
to the anti-poverty program
that was in development--
in the developmental stage
when John F. Kennedy
was assassinated.
By at the end of 1962 then,
Robert Kennedy began speaking
about racial segregation and
discrimination as a national,
not a regional problem.
In March of '63,
addressing the gathering--
the Commemoration
of the Centennial
of the Emancipation
Proclamation in Kentucky,
he told the gathering
that the problems created
by racial discrimination
were massive.
He continued, the results of
racial discrimination carry
on for generation
after generation.
To face this openly and try
to meet it squarely is the
challenge of this decade.
Martin Luther King had begun
his campaign in Birmingham
and within weeks said that it
was edging towards what would
seem like a race war.
During the first week of May,
images of the city's
police assaulting hundreds
of protesting black
youth with dogs
and high-pressure fire
hoses blanketed the nation
and were beamed across
the world,
thrusting America's
racial conflict
to the forefront of
public awareness.
Police violence, mob
terror, and the bombing
of the hotel housing Martin
Luther King Jr. brought
thousands of blacks into
the streets of Birmingham
and ignited pent-up
despair and anger
in America's urban areas
across the country.
A wave of mass demonstrations
amplified the prophetic warning
in James Baldwin's
"The Fire Next Time",
which had been published
several months earlier.
Birmingham brought
urgent efforts
to push beyond normal channels
and find the nations capacity
to resolve a problem woven
deep into American life.
On May 17th, Robert Kennedy and
Burke Marshall outlined plans
for a Civil Rights Bill.
And the Justice Department
lawyers began
drafting legislation.
Kennedy initiated and attended
endless rounds of meetings
in Washington and New York.
At the same time, he lobbied
national business leaders
to voluntarily end segregation
in their southern-based stores,
movie theaters, and
other public facilities.
There were small private
meetings with national, civic,
business, philanthropic,
and political leaders
to build support for a major
Civil Rights legislation.
On May 24th, in a
highly unusual meeting,
he met with a small
group of black activists
and artists convened
by James Baldwin,
hoping to seek their
advice on what could be done
to counter the appeal of Malcolm
X and other militant groups.
And, you know, you had a sense
when you're in this period
that things are on edge.
The gathering-- And I've
spent a lot of time on this,
but just a little bit, but it
quickly dissolved into an attack
on the failure of the Kennedy
administration to do more
and to effectively
address the depths
of the racial crisis
throughout the country,
racial discrimination.
At several points,
he tried to intervene
and shift the conversation
and it didn't work,
so he retreated into silence.
By all accounts, the meeting, it
went on and they just unloaded
on him about everything.
By all accounts, the meeting
was a remarkable display,
and we don't pay enough
attention to this, of the divide
in experience and understanding
for someone even as--
well, you know, interested and
concerned as Robert Kennedy
and his black contemporaries.
Kenneth Clark said, "We might
as well have been speaking
different languages."
"But," he added, "the
fact that Bobby sat there
through such an ordeal for
three hours," in his house,
his apartment, Clark commented,
"proved that he was among,
he was among," and this what
some Lorraine Hansberry said
to him, if you don't get
it, we're in big trouble
because you are among the best
white America has to offer.
A week later, Robert Kennedy
was with the president
when John F. Kennedy decided
that he would go ahead
and introduce comprehensive
Civil Rights legislation,
a tough decision that
Kennedy acknowledged--
John F. Kennedy acknowledged
as morally right and essential
to meeting this crisis.
But he told his brother that
it would probably be his
political swansong.
There's a real concern that
it will cost him the election
and all of his aides
thought that
and they told him not to do it.
But he wanted to wait until
after the desegregation
of the University of Alabama
on June 11th before
acting on this decision.
That afternoon, following
the peaceful inauguration
of the university, he decided
to go on television at 7 o'clock
and announce plans to
introduce the Civil Rights Bill.
So there's much frantic activity
for several hours as he worked
with his brother
and Speechwriter Ted Sorensen
sketching out what he would say.
President Kennedy's
June 11th speech,
parts of it written down, most
of it spoken extemporaneously,
reflected the strong
influence of his brother.
There were echoes of Robert
Kennedy's South Carolina speech
and interestingly,
Kenneth Clark will stunned
and somewhat reassured to
hear phrases and concerns
that they had expressed
during their meeting
with Robert Kennedy woven
into the president's speech.
It's an amazing, wonderful,
extraordinary speech
which everyone should read.
The president described
the human toll
of America's racial past and
the lost futures of children
who are attending segregated
schools, nearly a decade
after the Brown Ruling.
He spoke with deep conviction
about the urgency of the moment
"the fires of frustration
and discord are burning
in every city, North
that South."
And he insisted that there
was a moral imperative to act.
This is a problem that faces us
all, not merely as presidents,
congressmen, or governors,
but every citizen of
the United States.
And again, just to
highlight this period,
just hours after he gave this
speech, Medgar Evers was gunned
down in his driveway and
killed in Jackson, Mississippi.
On June 26, 1963, HR 7152
was introduced in the House
of Representatives and as head
of the Sponsoring Department,
Robert Kennedy was
the first to testify.
Burke Marshall recalled,
told Victor Navasky,
when President Kennedy sent
up that Civil Rights Bill,
every single person who spoke
about it in the White House,
every one of them was against
President Kennedy sending
up that bill, against
his speech in June,
against making it a moral issue.
The conclusive voice within
the government at that time,
there is no question
about it at all,
that Robert Kennedy was the one.
He urged it, he felt it, he
understood it, and he prevailed.
I don't think that
there was anyone
in the cabinet except the
president himself who felt
that way on these issues.
And the president got
it from his brother.
Now someone told me
that in the exhibit,
there's a film showing
Kennedy being--
deciding whether to make the
speech or not and the look
on his face and his
brother working with him
to bring him to agree
to do that.
So it's right down that exhibit,
you can see how this plays out.
So, work towards the bill--
the bipartisan collation for the
bill begins and the books by--
the Wayland's [inaudible]
book on the bill and Risen
and Todd Purdum, kind of getting
to the nitty-gritty of that.
A lot of it happens
under the Kennedy watch,
they get McCullough
lined up immediately,
and then just the tough work
of patching that together.
But it's again important
to remember,
as the bill moves forward, we
have the march on Washington
which captivates the nation and
King's "I have a dream" speech,
and then on September 15th-- I'm
going to go to my PowerPoint.
Sorry. I'm technically
challenged here.
I want to move forward.
That's '63, a rally that spring.
But I don't want to
put that up there.
The Klansmen bomb, it was right
after school desegregation
finally began in Alabama,
George Wallace tried to oppose
it, he couldn't stop it,
the schools are being
desegregated,
and Klansmen bombed the
16th Street Baptist Church
that September, killing
four girls aged 11 to 14.
The day after the
bombing of the church,
the Prince Edward Country Free
School opened in Farmville,
fulfilling Robert
Kennedy's efforts.
For the first time in four
years, 1,500 black children
in Prince Edward County
were able to attend school.
Of course, as we know, President
Kennedy was assassinated
that November 22nd.
Lyndon Johnson made passage
of the Civil Rights Bill,
John F. Kennedy's Civil Rights
Bill, his first priority.
No memorial, oration, or eulogy
could more eloquently honor
President Kennedy's memory
than that earliest passage
of the Civil Rights Bill for
which he fought for so long.
He failed to add with
the steadfast help
and work of his brother.
The political master worked in
tandem with a remarkable array
of forces, most significantly
the team that Kennedy had built
in the Civil Rights division.
I read an interview by Frank
Valeo, who was Secretary
of the Senate then and
he said, Burke Marshall
and Nicholas Katzenbach, I mean
they knew the bill inside-out,
they lobby very effectively,
they were as important,
if not more important
than Lyndon Johnson.
Now I don't think we
need to assign credit,
but it's important to
think of this foundation.
And I've heard it said
that they wouldn't have--
it wouldn't have passed
without Lyndon Johnson.
Well, it wouldn't have been
a bill without the Kennedy's.
And I think the work of
the Civil Rights division
that Robert Kennedy built
is enormously important
and overlooked to
a great extent,
and of course this remarkable
coalition that comes together
and helps to see this
bill pass a filibuster.
The bill passed on-- passed
the Senate just about the end
of the day, its introduction the
previous June, and on July 2nd,
Lyndon Johnson signed
the Civil Rights Act,
one of the most important
and transformative laws
in the history of
the United States.
Two weeks later,
a police shooting
of James Pal [assumed spelling],
a 15-year-old black teenager
in New York City, ignited
race riots in Harlem
and Bedford-Stuyvesant,
signaling a turn
that revealed the fragility of
the coalition that had grown
up during in 1960s
and preview to a new,
even more challenging phase
of America's long
struggle with race.
Shortly before he left the
department to run for Senate
in August of 1964, Robert
Kennedy met with Lyndon Johnson
and then he followed it up with
a memo urging the president
to convene a conference
of mayors and begin
to systematically address
America's city's, housing,
education, poverty,
criminal justice issues.
Elected to the Senate
from New York that fall,
Robert Kennedy emerged
as a political leader
in his own right during
a transitional time
for the country and for
Kennedy in aftermath
of his brother's assassination.
Jack Newfield has commented
or commented in his book,
"Experience began to
stretch, Bobby Kennedy,
tragedy transformed him."
In ways similar to Martin
Luther King, Kennedy began
to concentrate attention
on the deep-rooted racial,
economic inequities, and
injustices that had been exposed
by the Civil Rights Movement and
did not lend themselves to easy
or to clearer solutions.
And they both worked
to cultivate
and expand upon the promise
of the Civil Rights years.
This Kennedy speaking.
"We have gone as for as goodwill
and even good legislation
will take us.
We must now act to bring about
changes in the conditions
which breed intolerance
and discrimination",
he commented late in
the spring of 1965.
In August '65, a riot
in the Watts section
of Los Angeles just five days
after Lyndon Johnson signed
the Voting Rights Act,
marked the most deadly
and destructive riots
in American history, once again
ignited by long-term problems
of police violence and abuses.
Five days of rioting claimed
34 lives and $400 million--
$40 million in property damage.
Kennedy and his aide,
Peter Edelman went--
traveled to Los Angeles,
where they confronted--
and I think I've got
this little phrase right,
what Peter Edelman described
as the warzone here
in our own country.
Former President Eisenhower
echoed a growing refrain
claiming that the problem facing
American cities was the need
for greater respect for the law.
I'll go back to this.
All right.
Kennedy countered,
there's no point
in telling Negroes
to obey the law.
To many Negroes, the
law is the enemy.
In Harlem, Bedford-Stuyvesant,
it has almost always
been used against them.
In the aftermath of Watts, King
turns his head into Chicago
with his campaign to end slums
and Robert Kennedy
initiated plans
of what would become the
Bedford-Stuyvesant Restoration
Project, a bold experiment-- a
bold public-private partnership
which is much written about
and it's fascinating,
a remarkable effort.
The first community development
corporation of the country,
it was organized around
a systematic attack
on ghetto conditions.
Programs focused of job
training and creation,
housing restoration
and construction,
health and recreation,
schooling, economic development.
Kennedy said early on, you
know, problems in factions
and because the community
was directly, you know,
had full partnership in this
when they were fundraising,
people they raised money from,
government money,
philanthropists.
So Kennedy said early on, I'm
not sure it's going to work
but it's going to
test some new ideas,
some new ways of doing things.
Even if we fail, we'll have
learned, but more important
than that, something
must be done.
People like myself can't go
around making nice
speeches all the time.
We've got-- We have to do
some damn hard work too.
Problems of race and poverty
and of faith in the capacity
of Americans to act
collectively to begin
to remedy these injustice--
injustices were at the center
of Robert Kennedy's
public life as a senator,
and his presidential candidacy.
He traveled to cities
around the country.
He exposed himself to the depths
of rural poverty
in the Deep South.
Here he is with of Marian
Wright Edelman in Mississippi,
where he traveled
in '67 and horrified
by the poverty he saw there, and
to the conditions and struggles
against the poverty
in South Africa.
In one of his last
speeches given the day
after Martin Luther
King was killed,
and that's the night
he gave an amazing speech
off the back of a truck,
which everyone should read.
And the next morning,
he gave one more speech,
the last until King was-- until
the funeral, but he wanted
to talk about what he called
the mindless menace of violence.
And just to phrase from
that remarkable speech,
he spoke about the kind of
violence that was slower
but just as deadly, destructive
as the shot or the bomb
in the night, this is the
violence in institutions,
indifference, and in
action and slow decay.
This is the violence
that affects the poor,
and poisons relations
between men
because their skin
has different colors.
This is the slow destruction
of a child by hunger,
and schools without books,
and homes without
heat in the winter.
The question is whether we
can find in our own midst
and our own hearts that
leadership of humane purpose
that will recognize the terrible
truths of our existence.
But I want to end on another
note that was equally part
of his approach and feeling
about the moment he was living
and working in, words
to the young anti-apartheid
activist he visited
in South Africa in June of 1966,
which really I think
captured the spirit
of the Civil Rights
legacy-- Movement's legacy,
as well as Robert Kennedy's.
The road toward equality
and freedom is not easy
and great cost and
danger march alongside us.
Still, even in the turbulence
of protest and struggle,
there is greater hope for the
future as men learn to claim
and achieve for themselves
the rights formally petitioned
by others.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Some questions?
Questions, comments?
Yes?
>> On the map you showed,
there was a lot of Department
of Justice action in
Mississippi and Alabama.
And I was just curious
why not so much
in Georgia or South Carolina?
Why was that [inaudible]
chosen by Kennedy and--
>> That was actually all
throughout the South,
but they had a-- he wanted, you
know, cases in every country
in those three Deep
South states.
I guess they will
consider it the, you know,
the most resistant and toughest.
And it was Mississippi who
had a major project going
on with SNCC.
So, it wasn't that it weren't in
other countries but there was a,
you know, a concentrated
effort given their, you know,
resources and lawyer power.
But I haven't read a
specific explanation of that.
But I would assume that was it.
And I'm sorry, I'll
repeat the question.
That was a question about why
the Justice Department map,
the pins were concentrated
in three states
and whether the Justice
Department was active
in other states in the South?
Yes?
>> The Kennedy's did not
like President Johnson
or Vice President Johnson.
What do you think Bob Kennedy
thought towards Johnson
after passing the
Civil Rights Act?
Did he change opinion?
>> You know, I think personally,
I mean-- as we all get older,
we know there are people
we don't get along with,
there are conflicts
and tensions.
I think too much attention
in terms the relationship
between John F. Kennedy
and Lyndon Johnson,
I think we get too
caught up in that.
I think that, you know, one
thing that really strikes me
after knowing this history more,
how cold Lyndon Johnson was
to him when he signed
the Civil Rights Act.
Robert Kennedy made it
possible for Lyndon Johnson
to have that bill to sign.
That is a fact of
history which--
And I think that's important.
How they felt about each other?
That's deeply psychological,
personal,
it did not inhibit
this work, you know,
and I think that's
important too.
But I think it's important for
scholars to really look at.
And the other thing is that, you
know, as Robert Kennedy develops
and evolves and opens up
his concerns to the nature
of racial inequality and the
deep problem this country had,
historically grounded
and structural.
Lyndon Johnson, his response
to the urban violence,
his response, you know, we
had money going to the war
in Vietnam, poverty
funds shrinking,
so very different paths
that they both travel during
this post Civil Rights Voting
Rights period.
And Robert Kennedy's leadership
and growth during this era is
very significant and important
in terms of thinking about his
role in the 1960s around these--
the struggles and issues.
Peter.
>> Can you talk a little
bit more about the--
both President Kennedy
and RFK's relationship
to the Civil Rights Movement
in terms of finally handing
out to the president and making
the proposal for the '64 Act?
>> Patricia A. Sullivan: The
relationship of John F. Kennedy
and Robert Kennedy to the Civil
Rights Movement, you know,
that's-- I hope to learn more
about that as I go forward.
I think it's better than
we've been led to believe.
And I also think historians
have been too quick to kind
of take the perspective of
the activist on the ground,
which is important, you know,
what they're going through
and what they're experiencing.
And not realizing
the-- what was--
they were trying to do at
federal level and the kind
of constraints that existed.
So-- But I do know that
Robert Moses now talks
about John Doris, this lawyer.
And he talks about, you know,
what it meant to have access.
They had clear access
to the Civil Rights
Division at all times.
And I interviewed
Thelton Henderson
who was the only African
American attorney hired to--
well, the first, and
this is something,
to work in the field,
on this field team.
And he told me-- he got
to know, of course, King.
He had to stay in the hotels
where a lot of the-- in--
especially in Birmingham,
the Gaston.
That he felt that movement
people knew the Kennedy
administration was
responsive and that helped
to generate the momentum
of the movement.
So I think that's a
great question and I hope
that the work I'm doing will
help open it up and sort
of contextualize it a
bit more than looking
at this side, that side.
Our country.
I mean the segregation-- you
know, the way people felt
about this issue, how
deeply entrenched it was,
and this is democracy, right?
The political challenges
were huge.
And when they were debating
that bill, what was happening
in the north around the World's
Fair and all, at one point,
McCullough says the deal was
off if they protest at the--
you know, blocked traffic
to the World's Fair.
So the context is very fragile.
And I think what you see with--
in the Kennedy administration
is this,
especial the Civil
Rights Division
and Robert Kennedy pushing,
trying to find ways to go.
But that relationship I think, I
hope I can take a closer look at
and have something
fresh to say, thanks.
>> The video clip from
the exhibit was used a lot
because it's very reflective
of that relationship,
the Kennedy relationship.
Bobby was the only
one that spoke up
and said you have
to give a speech.
And it's a fly on the
wall documentation.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
That's right.
>> Of the relationship.
And then the subsequent
clip of the speech itself
when Kennedy [inaudible] went
contemporaneous without a script
for four minutes and that speech
on live TV in a convincing way.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
Oh yeah, he --
>> Without mentioning the act at
all, but focusing on community
and activity in the community
and the need for racial justice.
That is a real key.
For those that haven't
seen that,
[inaudible] taken
a moment of that--
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
That's right.
>> -- that fly on the
wall, why they were there
with that camera at that time.
I just don't see
that insider view.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
You know, I think that--
I think that's so terrific
that there's a film
of this discussion about should
he give the speech that night.
The-- I think that's what
you call crisis and sort
of a cinema verite
where a camera
who follows George Wallace all
that day and Robert Kennedy.
And I think maybe they
were the ones who filmed
that episode in--
when they were talking
about whether to
give the speech.
I'm going to run and go and see.
>> I can go back and see that--
>> Patricia A. Sullivan: Yeah.
>> -- because I think that's
real key to that relationship
and how things proceeded.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
No, very important.
It's wonderful that it's here.
And that-- Can that be
obtained online as well?
>> I think it's online.
>> Not yet.
>> We're working on it.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan: OK.
That would be great.
I mean for teaching, it would
be terrific for teaching.
Yes. OK.
>> I wonder if there was
that three-hour meeting
with intellectuals and artists,
was it a one time
only conversation
or did these conversations
with those people
continue [inaudible]?
If not, [inaudible] they
still opened up a dialogue.
Or was it just that one time?
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
That's a great question.
If-- The people that Robert
Kennedy met with James Baldwin,
Harry Belafonte [assumed
spelling], Lena Horne,
number about 10 people in
the end of May of 1963.
He and Belafonte continued.
I mean he felt that Belafonte
didn't step up, you know,
during that discussion.
He thought that Belafonte
knew him.
But-- So it was just
so divisive.
But I don't have any
evidence that he and Baldwin--
They weren't, you
know, they met and all.
And again, this period,
it's so intense.
I think Kenneth Clark, Kenneth
Clark really respect Robert
Kennedy and he thought he got it
about education and
about children.
So-- But I should
trace that out.
I don't know for sure, yup.
Yes.
>> What do you think are
the most important lessons
for young advocates who are
still working on the issues
of racial discrimination
and police brutality [inaudible]
could learn from Robert Kennedy?
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
What are the lessons
for people working today around
issues of police brutality
and violence that we're seeing?
What can they learn
from Robert Kennedy?
I think first of all, what,
people even facing issue, right?
I mean just facing the issue
and trying to understand it.
You know, going,
talking to people,
and trying to build a
collective response.
You know what I mean,
to deal with the abuses
and the violations of law.
But then how do we
organize ourselves locally,
starting locally,
and as a country
because these are the issues
that we're left in
the late '60s.
I mean it's really
eerie to think
about how similar they are.
But I think that's-- And to
understand too the long haul.
That's what I tell my
students, it's the long haul.
It's really.
What-- We've been-- We've
lived with a lot of this,
but we have had tremendous
change.
And Robert Kennedy, how he lived
his life and faced the issues
and worked actively to do
his part and work with people
to begin to make some changes,
not just around criminal
justice issues but education.
All these things are
connected, that he was concerned
about in this part of his life,
so to work on the
various community issues
that also are such a problem.
Do you have a thought
about that though yourself?
>> I think, you know,
we still face--
I think that the
perception of what happens
in the police brutality issues.
I think that it's still
very racially divided based
on experience because
people are [inaudible].
I think that in terms of
domestic transportation issue,
that's another racially
divided issue because I think
that the perception of
people who don't deal
with racial conflict on a
day-to-day basis is that--
well, the people who deal
with those isolate events.
They're isolated.
You know, they only
happen sometime,
it's because of their
characters,
because they're [inaudible].
But then when you
think of the holistic,
like what you're saying
about education and community
and environment, there's so many
different reasons why people may
end up in those type
of situations,
whether it'd be going to jail or
being suspended by the police.
And I think that
lack of perception,
that lack of knowledge
and that lack
of experience just
creates an unwillingness
to accept what's
happening for people
who don't live in
those situations.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
You said-- That's--
Thank you for that,
lack of knowledge,
lack of experience,
lack of caring too.
That litany he read
or said at his--
and he said that in a number
of places about the difference
between the gap between what
African Americans and whites,
you know, in all areas.
Like, that continues the measure
of, you know, of the difference
in economic opportunity,
educational access, income,
you know, dealings
with the police.
So, you know, we need
to look at our history
and understand who we are.
You know, and that's
what he said.
He said when he spoke after
King, who are we as a country?
And people really need to look
at our history to
understand that.
And where do we want
to go, you know.
And I think looking at this
in this larger context can add
to that in this moment.
Yes?
>> I think that one
of the lessons was people
should take more walks.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
I think that's true too,
take more walks.
Yes. Marilyn.
>> Just one.
First, thank you so much--
[ Inaudible ]
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
That's-- Yeah.
That's-- And that
really is what's
at the center of their concern.
And Peter Edelman, not
to put you on the spot
but I've read there's
several places that--
I mean, thinking about--
I've been really interested in
how King and Kennedy are kind
of moving in very
similar directions.
They didn't see a lot
of each other and all,
but they're really-- and the
Poor People's Campaign that you
and Marian had been visiting
with Robert and Ethel Kennedy
and he suggested to
Marian that she'd tell King
to bring the poor
people to Washington
and stay there until--
and Marian goes to the
SCLC Convention that summer
and the Poor People's
Campaign is launched.
So, maybe Dr. King
was thinking about.
But the important thing is
they're thinking along the
same ways.
And that thing about
yourself, people have got
to make demands, right?
I mean, who represents poor
people, poor people, right?
That's a huge-- Would you
like to speak to that point
that Marilyn made
about what to do?
I mean, you teach
a poverty seminar
about the current
economic crisis
and how that affects-- Yeah.
[ Inaudible ]
No, that's important.
>> And going back to
the act side of it,
the ways in which the
inequality has just exacerbated
so many other, other problems.
And I do think that there's
a-- just like you said,
like there's a-- sort of
a disconnect with-- of--
at least we'll see what
comes out of these current
and recent events but it's a
very [inaudible] while we're
at it, talking about gender.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan: Right.
Race and gender.
Yes. Great.
[ Inaudible ]
I think-- What's the
legacy of Robert Kennedy?
I think it's that-- well, the
work he was doing right then
at the end of his life is left
for us to do now, you know.
I mean, that he was doing it.
And, you know, that experiencing
nature, I love that note,
she lived in his world.
And, you know, he
said at one point,
you don't make the
world, you inherited it.
You inherit, but you
live in it, and you need
to do what you can while
you're here, you know.
So, you didn't create
the problems, fine,
but you're living here now.
And I think that approach
and that sort of civic sense
of responsibility and a real--
a faith in democracy not in
a nave way, but in that--
what it takes to address these
issues and to be part of trying
to move things forward.
It's a living legacy
because he kept growing.
He just kept throughout
his life.
And during this extraordinary
decade when public service
and people really felt they
could change things, many people
and dedicated themselves
to trying to do that,
but that's always available
and it's really the only way.
>> I think one of his famous
quotes every man can make a
difference and each
man should try.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
That's good.
Every man can make a difference
and each man should try.
Yeah. Should we take one more?
Yeah?
[ Inaudible ]
At his death, were there any--
this is a question for Peter.
I don't know, but I think it's
evident in what he was saying
and doing and-- like the
Bedford-Stuyvesant project,
other things.
You know, the question
is, what--
any indication of what his
policies would have been going
forward, what his plans were.
>> Oh I could-- Number one,
end the war in Vietnam.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
Yes, end the war.
>> Absolutely number one, but
as far as these issues of praise
and poverty together,
the thing--
he was very three-dimensional
in terms of things
that he pushed forth and so on.
So-- But the thing,
it was certainly also
the top for him was jobs.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
Jobs, OK.
>> And of course that very much
you were talking-- asking--
talking about Dr.
King that was--
he had gone in that
direction as well.
And specifically,
the whole question,
I heard somebody say this
morning and where I was
that that you can tell
person's life expectancy
by their zip code.
And that he certainly when you
talked about Bedford-Stuyvesant,
he was-- again, there would
have been many other ideas
but very much in the forefront
for him was the question
of what are we going to do
in this neighborhood
[inaudible] as well.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan: Right.
>> Where there's so many
people who were in poverty
who were all packed together.
And I think that was
on the domestic side
and the questions
have raised on poverty
about which he was absolutely
have them conjoined in his mine.
Particularly, King with the
focal point on the question
of concentrated poverty.
>> Patricia A. Sullivan:
Concentrate, thank you.
Thank you.
That's great explanation.
OK. Anything else?
OK. Thank you.
Thank you [applause].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.